the hottest man in America get those  raincoats ready ladies the Peter Brady  look-alike this back trying to to date  25 or more people you know you don't  train for that  to recap Ben was the guy rejected by  Caitlin on last season's The  Bachelorette now on the 20th season of  The Bachelor  the man hungry ladies are fighting over  him she hit me in the face and kind of  puta Sh  my goal was like really good to know  everybody so I'm hoping that leading  through this that at least up until the  fantasy suites that we can not  concentrate as much on the physical part  but really concentrate on the part of  getting to know each other through the  experiences that were gonna share so no  sex too soon but what about those rumors  he hooked up with the next girlfriend  before shooting the season I think I  learned about my life sometimes through  the tabloids I'll read stuff I'm like oh  that's interesting that happened to me  because I don't got an in experiences